I was here in LA actually advertising
some other film and and I got a script
and a letter at the four seasons saying
we're making Paddington part 2 and
there's a part of a washed-up
narcissistic demented monster of an
axiom we thought you'd be perfect your
initial reaction Cheers
where do you think you're going bear did
you think there was room for a second
year for a second year
there's never has never room for a
second you in fact you there's no lens
wide enough to accommodate to use I
think you're in great shape for a man
your age mr. Brown Thank You Paddington
hang on how old do you think I am Oh
about 80 80 released were you worried
about the second one sometimes when you
make a good film that's well received
and they go to make a second one you're
like oh is this one gonna be as good as
comparable to the first yeah there's
always a bit of you know second now on
the syndrome and but I think poor poor
King on whose shoulders as the writer
director on whose shoulders that burden
fell we know managed to where it likely
I didn't give a monkey's butt he was the
one who's gonna hit a slap in the face
if it was a disaster luckily I think
it's as in challenging if not more so
than the first throughout the course of
your career both of you I'm sure you've
taken a roller taking something that
after you look back you're like oh my
god mmm acid IIIi did I want to did an
advert for a newspaper when I was about
18 and it was absolutely appalling and I
realized I'm not very good at birds went
away yourself I've regretted it I think
every film I've ever made to be really
honest there's a funny story I read
about I guess it was a teacher you had
dressed up when you were really young as
a female and she had liked the way you
had portrayed this female and that's one
of the reasons you got into acting my
school was all boys and so when we did
plays we all played you know the ones of
us who are underdeveloped and pretty
played the girls parts and so i yeah i'm
always very sympathetic to the plight of
actresses because i was one for so long
five or six years that's what I did was
female parts he's a master of disguise
wizard about this franchise that that's
made it so successful I suppose I
suppose it's because the the carriage of
the center of it obviously Paddington is
some as a character that we all identify
with we've all been that bear not
literally but we bought you know we've
all felt lost and alone in a strange
place and relied on the kindness of
strangers to help us out and we've tried
to fit in in a new environment at school
or a new town or new country or whatever
and and I so I think that's one of the
reasons we love him we want to look
after him and we want to have fun with
him and see what scrapes he gets into